problem 75
two airplanes left the same airport
traveling in opposite directions if one
plane averages
400 miles per hour so let's see one this
is the airport one plane goes in that
direction at
miles per miles per hour that's a mile
not a meter and the airplane averages
250 miles per hour it's going the other
direction so it's going at 250
and i do this as vectors so kind of the
the
length of the my arrow represents
its speed to some degree and the
direction represents direction
250 miles per hour in the that direction
400 miles per hour in that direction and
how many hours will the distance between
the two planes be 16 25 miles so you
just have to say from if you're if
you're sitting in this plane right here
this plane is the left
and you don't know you know let's say
you think you're stationary how far is
how fast is that plane going to be
moving to to the right words direction
or i guess in this to the east in the
eastward direction well from your point
of view it's going to be going to the in
the east direction at 650 miles per hour
right if you thought that you were
stationary just be going away from you
at 650 miles per hour
650 miles per hour
right same thing if you were sitting in
this plane right here and you thought
you were stationary and you are relative
to yourself you say oh why this guy is
going to the west at 650 miles per hour
relative to me and we're starting at the
same point so this just becomes a
standard distance is equal to rate times
time problem
so if we have to cover 16 25 miles
because that's why they want to know you
know when does that happen at what point
are the planes that far from each other
that is equal to
their relative velocity the they're
separating from each other at 650 miles
per hour
and we want to know how long that's
going to take
so time is he going to is going to equal
16 25 divided by 650
see if we can simplify that at all well
we could divide the
top and the bottom by 25
right if we divide the top one well let
me just get my calculator
so 16
25 divided by 650
is equal to 2.5
oh yeah 2.5
so time and we were doing everything in
miles per hour so time's going to be
equal to 2.5 hours
this choice a
problem 76.
i should copy and paste all of these
word problems we'll parse them together
problem 76
in green
green
lisa will make punch that is 25 fruit by
adding pure fruit juice
to a 2 liter mixture that is 10 percent
pure fruit juice
okay
how many liters of pure fruit juice does
she need
to add pure fruit juice so let's let p
is equal to
liters
of pure
and that's what that's what they want us
to figure out so we have to figure out p
all right and let's say that adding to a
2 liter mixture so let's say m is equal
to the liter of mixture liters
of the mixture
that is ten percent
fruit juice right
so that is this right here
to a two liter mixture that is ten
percent fruit juice we're calling that m
that is the two liter mixture that is
ten percent fruit juice
okay how many liters of pure fruit juice
does she need to add
okay so let's think about it a little
bit
so
the total amount of
she's going to add a punch so she's
going to add punch
so punch is going to be pure juice
right so she wants so let's think about
how much pure juice is going to be in
the system right
the liters of pure juicy adds
plus
the liters of the mixture
was a two liter mixture that is ten
percent fruit juice so how much fruit
juice is already there
so it's point two liters of fruit juice
right it's a two liter mixture
oh you know what i shouldn't even define
them we know that m is equal to two
so ignore that and you can tell i'm
doing these problems in real time i'm
struggling with them as you would anyway
so how much fruit juice is there going
to be in the mixture there's the amount
of liters of the pure fruit juice she
adds
and then this is a pure fruit juice pure
fruit juice that's p
and then you're going to have the two
liters of the mixture that is 10 fruit
juice so how much fruit juice is coming
from that
well 10 of 2 liters is 0.2 liters
already
and then how many liters is there going
to be in the mixture
and the combined how many total liters
are there well as the liters of the pure
fruit juice
plus the 2 liters that we're adding to
right this is the amount of pure this is
the amount of fruit juice this is the
total amount of liquid right and we got
the point two from ten percent times two
and we said that this has this has to
equal 25 percent we want this to be 25
of this so this should be 0.25
that was an inver in inadvertent mark
right down there so now we just solve
for p
now we just solve for p the hard part is
setting up the problem
cp so let's multiply p plus 2 times both
sides
so you get p
plus 0.2 is equal to 0.25 times this so
0.25
p
plus
0.25 times 2 is 0.5
fair enough let's subtract 0.2 from both
sides you get p
is equal to 0.25 p
0.5 minus 0.2 is plus 0.3
let's subtract 0.25 p from both sides 1p
minus 0.25 p is
0.75
p
is equal to 0.3
and let's see where this goes
did i do that right 0.75 p is equal to
0.3
right
okay and then you have
let's see you get
p so let's let me i the decimals
sometimes get confusing let's multiply
both sides of this equation by 10 you
get
7.5 p is equal to 0.3
sorry is equal to 3 we multiplied by 10.
so you get p is equal to 3 over 7.5
how many times does 7.5 go into 3. so
that's the same thing how many times
does 75 go into 30.
put a decimal sign
let's see it goes into it i think 4
times right 4 4 times 5 is 020
right
4 times so it's 0.4 so p is equal to 0.4
liters we have to add 0.4 liters of
fruit juice of pure fruit juice
to the 2 liter mixture so you add 0.4 to
the 2-liter mixture so you end up with
0.6
liters of pure fruit juice so the
numerator becomes 0.6 and the
denominator becomes yeah this was 0.4
this becomes 2.4 which sure enough is
one-fourth or 25 percent
fascinating problem
next question
and these are good to learn you know a
lot of times in math class people like
oh you know what do i need to learn this
for but this type of algebra you're
going to use it all the time especially
if you go into
any type of science or engineering or or
for that matter investing or finance
you're going to use these kind of you
know boy can i figure this out or not
type of equations all the time when
you're mixing things and figuring out
margins and all the rest okay let's see
which relation is a function
so i have a little bit of review of a
function so a function
is a relation that maps from a domain to
a range
and i haven't looked at these yet but
the catch here is
oh i want to say from a to b or we could
say from the domain to the range
right
where it takes one set of numbers which
we call the domain
and we have another set of numbers and
for every number here there's exactly
one number in the range
right and that's a key there's only a
from here to here there's only one
number now two of these could meet the
same number but you can't have one
number here going to two separate
numbers there that's the key so what we
probably want to look for let's see
here we have the same number so this
this let me get a better color so you
have a minus 2 here
and you have a minus 2 here
so that's like the same number
you have a let's say this is the minus
2. that minus 2 is going to a 6
it's going to 6 and here it's going to a
minus 2.
so you have the same number going to two
different numbers and you can't have
that in a function for any given dom
number in the domain you definitely get
only one in the range so a is not the
answer
let's see does this have that same
problem
see every number is there exactly once
you have 1 minus 2 1 0 1 1 1 2. so
you're not going to have that problem my
suspicion is it's already b
see yeah you see c has the same problem
number 4 for every 4 goes this goes to a
bunch of different numbers 4 goes 4 goes
to 0 4 goes to 1 for it so it's not c
and then this defines two values for 10
so that doesn't work either so the
answer is b
b
problem
78
78
all right
this is
okay let me
for which equation graphed below are all
the y values negative so if all the y
values are negative we have to stay
below the x axis right this is where all
the y values are negative right there
so this one seems to work a seems to
work right here these aren't negative y
values these are positive y values
i didn't even copy and paste all these
but i can already see what you know
these are positive y values these are
positive y values so a was the answer
i'm sorry i ran out of space anyway i'll
see you in the next video right all of
these y values are all negative you're
staying in the third and fourth quadrant
all right next video